[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
hey do you think we have the balls to do
what drake did to vanessa hundreds oh
yeah what's up
what do you do it's an old uh old clip
love tonight and i just want to say
vanessa hudgins you look incredible
like right shoot her shoes
that's also drake i don't know austin
don't
i know we talked about this earlier i
said it goes in your relationship with
your girls it goes drake then you
yeah yeah cause you're not even me if i
was at the mtv music awards
and i'm sitting in front of my girl and
drake was like yo
i just want to say brent job your girl
is fine as [ __ ]
and i want to know what she's doing
after this week
that's exactly what you better run
through literally do the same thing that
you got
one [ __ ] knife he's got it
you better suck that right and tell him
to mention my name in the verse
you ever seen him you ever seen that
private jet that's what i'm saying
you better get us some drizzy gear out
of there so you could you could let your
girl do it i could
i could yeah i could drake's really
everyone
i love drake hey is there anybody else
no there's no one else there's no
there's no one else there's no one else
anyone else i'd probably fight that
movie i'm like i'm like you know shut
your ass up
come up on that knock your ass yeah if
like travis scott was like hey
and then no disrespect but your girl my
man [ __ ] you
beat y'all beat your ass i have a shirt
actually give me those bags can i get
the friends and family literally yeah if
it's straight it's only drake it's only
jake's the only guy i'd be like yeah go
ahead like if she asked me it was like
yo listen
like i'll take
[Laughter]
he's the only one i can't think of
another person i mean no
yeah what about someone from uh what's
that ban you love the
uh what's the bandwidth oasis oh no
you love them i love them you won't let
them run out
oh [ __ ]
listen i don't love him you understand
him you're right i understand him i
connect with drake so much
more more so than uh oasis uh i love
oasis more than drake and you wouldn't
let oasis
hey oh no run that manchester train on
your girl manchester
united yeah behind the gap look at see
mine the gap manchester doug get the
[ __ ] out of here
no man all right man you couldn't do it
you left drake
yeah that's what i'm saying you couldn't
name anyone else drake's my but drake's
my favorite
what about their baby i love the baby
but yeah
yeah that's that really you know he's
small though it don't matter he's
smiling
but like with drake i know i know he's
gonna treat her nice the baby probably
trained her right now
i know i know for sure with drake i've
heard a song even when she mad at me
still suck that dick but she's mad at me
that's a great yeah he might tell him
get the [ __ ] out of here right after you
know what
go back to your mate drake he'll walk
her downstairs
make sure she's getting the um
let me know if you want to borrow my
planes yeah that'd be sick you think the
baby's gonna do that yeah no
i think so i don't think the baby don't
have a plane i was on the plane with the
baby oh you was on the plane with the
baby oh
soon first class though he was the first
class all this homelessness isn't
commercial
you know what you know i applaud y'all
for saying that a lot of me wouldn't do
it yeah i would yeah 100 like her that's
drake
anybody else nah nah no one i literally
try to think like if
like she came and like yo man like i had
sex with
you you can't think if she said drake
i'm like well girl how are you like i
mean
with drake like yeah because you want to
know obviously
because listen that's how you know you
got a good girl exactly because if
drake's a tight it's a tight it's a type
if drake's like damn yeah yeah she bad
maybe adam sandler my girl's like god
that's
though there's someone's alone like
trying to think
wait let the man speak all right i'm
just trying to think like what
what other icons could take a stab at my
girl i would be offended adam sandler
i'll be so sad i'll be so upset i'm like
hold on man the longest
see if we give me a cameo and grown-up
stuff
when you're done
you can get that with your agent oh
you're right
what he's handsome he's not legend
status
yet though you know he also grew up kind
of nerdy
yeah in the comic book yeah yeah yeah he
was super nerdy
oh really yeah yeah cornball what's
wrong i mean drake grew up nerdy didn't
he
yeah there's something about drake
though right swag you know what you know
michael b is like you can tell like he's
like trying to be all sexy and big gets
home he's like
okay thank god like drake it just stays
the same you know
you know drinking he's cool no matter
why yeah
he's so dope and that's that toronto
bench
have you ever seen that dude so what if
he he was like yeah you can bring your
man to come chill at the back
oh dude it's so big dude all right babe
have fun
i'm like hey which one's the source for
the youtube videos
i'll be in that pool i'll be in there
just really just think i'm like yo man
you mind if i check out your shoe
collection
he's like yeah i'll be on a second all
right have fun oh yeah yeah yeah yeah do
you think
you know you buried your teeth he's like
order whatever you want i'm like oh
hell yeah the chef is already in the
kitchen you got a chef already dumped
his feet's all propped up you mind if i
shoot around in your
record yeah do whatever you want man my
place is yours
i feel like you would say that right my
place yours man me and your girl gonna
go back here
my place is your like thanks dude is
that the better one the toronto house
yeah
yeah
that's the house i thought the calabasas
one was like no the toronto's
the big boy the toronto's the the walls
that he put around oh that's the toronto
yeah someone tried to break in yesterday
really yeah a woman inside the metal
pipe and a woman a knife
trying to break in and she ended up
attacking one of his bodyguards but she
didn't get past the gate
it was so funny is it would be a woman
to break into the drinks
that's the same only women are trying to
break it yeah only women are trying to
break in
so it's seven mil i thought it'd be more
than no it's 100
100 ml it has to be yeah it's a hundred
mil
because yeah what did he do he had a
custom built and where it's at in
toronto is like the brentwood of toronto
and the walls for security are so high
that there's a
like even where i live like you i
couldn't build 14
foot wall you see because it's like the
you see my walls they're 12.
yeah if i go any higher it's illegal
look how big those walls are guys so his
are like 25 foot walls
the city is he has the only house in the
city where they granted him
those walls because he's so famous
because the rest of the walls
have to be a certain height and even the
neighbors i guess drake he can have
bigger wallets i know
wow and listen some crazy [ __ ] scaled
that wall and still got it
see how much she loves drinks i know
they got drake living in the atlantic
think about that woman who got his name
tattooed on her forehead yeah
girl got her name got drinks yeah bro
if we love them think about these bro
when are we gonna get drake on
oh that's going to be a tough sell
i would love it that'd be so [ __ ] fun
just to get drake yeah she's committed
drake damn that's so good oh well she's
stable look at her cheeks yeah
oh [ __ ] that's tough that's oh
that's she looks insane wait go to that
bottom picture underneath like that
white boy
no no hurry up to your cheeks
she might be homeless she might have
lost a bed
yeah this isn't funny okay yeah could
you let me mention that big
not really my style no right i like your
room in the same area
that's too much too much unless he's got
all his homies
chilling there he said he said he used
walkie talkies to talk to his homies if
they uh
spend the night his crib really yeah
that's how big it is you couldn't just
call them but that's so bold so what
what is it was that his lobby
look at his crib though that's in his
house
yes you just have people around all the
time i would have to
i couldn't do it no it's like imagine if
you live in a museum you're literally
like a museum
like my boy todd's house is the biggest
house i know yeah in palm springs is
like
i walked down like two i mean where do
we where do you go from here man
yeah like what do we do that big castle
he's like he's like go change down there
yeah he lives by himself see i couldn't
do it
he has homies around all the time his
trainers there but it's like
it's not for me i get too lonely yeah
yeah even hotel rooms i get long they're
tight
yeah it's just too much i spread out
like i get lonely too it's great and i
don't like when it's
like i'm sleeping in a big open area
like look at his [ __ ] room
i know bro he's got couches on the side
yeah he's behind so i think it's like
the walls right here the beds right here
and then there's like couch
what is out there naked just dick
hanging out
he got a safe house that's what that's
where brendan will be chilling
what is that room that's the boom boom
that's the boom boom room that's
that's that's that's that 60 vibe that's
that's where he gets a dick sucked
oh what that what a afro is that [ __ ]
comp is that studio lounge is it like a
comic book before he makes
beats doug or is that superheroes that's
not his producer
oh yeah comics on the wall yeah you got
like actually no that's actually
like basketball players too yeah and the
hulk go to his jersey room that's that
was the best one that's why i'd be
chilling
his shoe room is insane oh yeah so many
shoes
damn uh drake's jersey room
yeah i couldn't do it i knew i could use
this [ __ ] it's a nice just a nice condo
it's fine
for me not that big
what about you malik could you uh live
in a big
uh i don't have it i saw something here
though yeah
like that but that doesn't look good
that's not fancy that [ __ ] is weak
it was in the 2d slide video where he
was uh walking around his crib
oh yeah and uh what is that like the
original jordan jersey or something
what which one the one that's in that
case oh that's the
that's the jordan 45 one when he came
it's when he came back
that [ __ ] is autographed and he lost bro
my car guy he's like one of my close
friends now his name is greg
he ju he was like dude look at this my
life's a [ __ ]
movie and he's uh selling a
car to michael jordan he's texting back
and forth with him he screenshot i'm
like holy [ __ ] that's mj he's like yeah
like holy [ __ ] dude
really what kind of car would he want to
[ __ ] drive a ferrari pista
i don't know if they're so hard to get
yeah wonderful
yeah look at that that's the that's the
one yeah some jersey kobe
you'll see it oh that's him in the video
god that dance is lit
look at his kitchen he doesn't get a
mess he doesn't miss a big ass piano you
gotta have a piano in your crib
that's some special piano too it is yeah
got his homies chilling i thought that
was kevin durant
wow it would be weird to be his homie
though
yeah if you're not if you're yes if
you're just like hanging out you just
like his friend yeah
his son's cute as [ __ ] too man that og
look at that he got the blue room the
red room hit a jersey road [ __ ]
look at the pool does he have a strip
club in there basically this
this on the side oh bro
brendan just out there doing cannonballs
in the pool
the first time the first time i came to
hollywood we both went right when i got
here
so someone invited me to like this
hollywood party the celebrity party
yeah and i'm from denver dude so when i
see a pool
and they told me pool party i came for a
pool party oh so i'm in like my swim
trunks
a wife beater i have my chains on
tattoos everywhere i see food i'm like
i'm in my head
i don't know anybody just a friend
invited me he goes off with some girl
i'm like [ __ ] i'm getting this pool
nobody's in it i'm like why anybody in
the pool i jump in the pool
splash around everywhere and i hear a
group of girls go
ugh why is he so big
how's that that was your first hollywood
outfit i just swam over
this big i was all self-conscious
looking around in the pool that's all
she was wearing with a t-shirt on
fish out of water you know what you
needed to do yeah you ready bro pool
parties is crazy out here i went to my
first one
because i used to swim at the ymca and
uh look at it
yeah well i i could swim though you
didn't oh yeah again black
you know the myth black people can't
swim stereotype stereotypes so i'm in
baldwin hills right
great like a black hollywood area right
i'll go there i'm like yo what's up
i got my swimming trunks and everyone is
fly chains on
jeans i'm like they tripping did the
same thing i was like
but i ain't getting the pool though i
just put my feet there oh i go pool pool
if i'm i mean if you you stay pulled
apart i'm swimming [ __ ]
i'm also probably gonna pee in your pool
you're gonna pee in your pool
i'm not walking into the house you're
gonna do laughs like michael phelps he's
hitting the whole thing
you know what i used to i'm gonna eat
your food i'm gonna pee in the pool and
call it a day he gonna get a cramp for
eating the food because
eating food because you're supposed to
wait like 20 minutes i'm gonna make some
demands on the plate on the playlist i'm
need some drake
you dance around the pool you never get
in it though that's what i heard out
here in l.a
unless you pick up a girl and throw her
in the pool and that's funny i can't
really realize i can't remember the last
time i've been in a pool
dude it's a thick boy summer so the pool
party's gonna start popping up
is it a thick boy summer yeah i keep
saying that but bro
i know well but i told you dude i told
you dude dude
so we do do do do dude we're thick no
matter what
even if we lose now you missed the
workout this morning
don't mean i'm not gonna work out today
that's fine all i'm saying
is even if you do we're going to stay
fit we're we've but look we're both
slimmer
still we are still thinking we're never
not going to be thanksgiving
and the more you accept that the better
your life is i did pull ups yesterday
you did yeah you did eight of them i did
eight it's impressive
this one [ __ ] did 24. 24 pull up i've
done pull-ups in four years and i did 20
bruh
he did 24. are you serious yeah yes 24
is like straight yeah 24 like this or
like this
yeah like this oh with your back your
back yeah
the the [ __ ] what the hard white
prison style wow
wait wait go away over this is to the
neck behind the board prison style that
one
not that prison oh think of federal put
it this way he started
going i went and walked to get a drink
of water he was still going he i come
back he's still going
yeah i was worried you should see mark
on those calabasas stairs this morning
well he was getting it
i was like just slow down daddy oh he's
gotta enjoy the view
there's hoes everywhere dog this one
girl just had
chits just boom i'm like mark
chill dog i know you see them big old
jobs he's just going dude just go i'm
like oh you
oh you came to work work how is it like
is that [ __ ] hard
no i mean it can be for him i'm sure it
was a good workout
for me i don't know if i get like i
don't know if i can consistently do it
but you can walk it like i ran to and
then walked ran two what do you mean
you go up down up down yeah
it's fun though get your confidence big
ass up here
i don't like the jump rope man stop
that's why i told him i was like
chapelle ain't coming under
that fiber that fiber rusty i know dude
i haven't seen you in
not a non-black shirt and i don't know
how long what shirt what shirt is that
super tour who's that metal band they're
they're hardcore hardcore
how hard pretty metal metal yeah play
some for me chin
metal metal metal metal right uh should
we do the old school so
what do you want oh you know who they
are he's gonna give me another shirt too
yeah i'm getting a shirt
it's gonna be loud that's axl yeah how
do
how you know you look good let's go
double daddy [ __ ] let's go double daddy
[ __ ] bro a little looser would be fun
[ __ ] you
he's run big [ __ ] shut up
hey the exhaust is lit it looks good
nice seriously i think it looks good no
i think it looks great yeah
uh i'll just play a little bit of the
old one i think i think once you wash it
once so it could be dangerous
you know sweaty i don't [ __ ] dry a
shirt no i will not
air dry dude my girls ruined so many
favorite shirts by drying them i'm like
you know what i can't i i first of all
jeans put them in the washroom and then
no game of thrones
ruin it
bruh i thought it was the only one that
did that bro i'm like i'm hanging out
yeah
i'll buy regular fitting jeans and i'll
put them in the dryer they they skinny
fit now don't
yeah if you want to keep winning they
skinny they're trying to skinny why
don't you just get a bigger size then
why don't you just go to the cleaners
because the weights because
those 38 eventually they stretch out but
like after you just got to wear them a
lot but you got to work
like when they first get out they
[ __ ] tight tight tight
you know what i'll wear around my house
like sweats break them in
oh really i do with my shoes too like i
wore these all day yesterday
just to break them in so they're not so
crispy like a glove oh
do they not fit uh they fit but that's
like how
flat they are this is them try to try to
play like yo you got flat feet i don't
know why you trying to act like you
don't have flash dude i have an
arch done no man it's like it's arched
yeah
britney you got a car dude i can see
your your foot spills off to the side
you can't even wear yeezys
i don't have flat feet hug no brendan i
haven't already got a hoof on you you
have it on
you compare my foot we can take our feet
out
on the table we know he's got flat feet
yeah exactly i'm saying his foot
i'm saying you got flat feet as well
your your feet look like two [ __ ]
hoverboards they're just flat
and again with all that yours is right
there with me what's that what's the
what's the
craft that can go there they're air and
they go on land and water
is it a hovercraft i don't know um oh
dang it what wait
people ride them in florida like gators
they see gators those are just airboats
those are airboats but i know you're
talking about oh
i guess hovercraft does work what is
that [ __ ] it's a hovercraft right yeah i
think so family has the big fan
what is that and like they have the big
like they take you through the swamp to
look
at is that what it is that's what your
feet look like
[Laughter]
i hear you no the blue one chin the
second one is
that's your foot okay i'm hearing all
that
he whipped yours is a big white thing
for the reason your padding is all white
underneath your feet
wait wait how the [ __ ] you know someone
got a let me see no he does he has flash
dude
his feet are spilling out the side i
know like a hovercraft
yours as well okay how tight you like
that bad [ __ ] in the club where one
pinky toe is sticking out oh [ __ ]
he whipped me i'm not though we both got
your pterodactyl feet
flat foot city right here for the city
flat flat foot
i don't know no no he got an no you have
no i do yeah you got a little you have a
flat foot cat
kind of it probably would have yeah do
it ever comment on your flat foot
huh you don't want like on only fans
they were like damn girl your feet are
flat
no like i have an arch but it's not
crazy stevie has a crazy arch in his
foot
really yeah it's really weird i don't
know
i'd like to see stevie put that little
foot in a high heel i don't know if
that's weird but i'd like to see his
little foot in the high heels
hit yeah
feet no no bro
i don't like it yesterday i have an
heart shot my feet malik those are your
[ __ ] toes brandon alex's foot
nah that's too much too much of an arch
for us brendan we got flat feet
oh gosh what happened to that we'll take
them out we'll take we'll take them out
of the end of this game
are disgusting looks like two flippers
they look like that thing just no king
of the stage it
those feet are disgusting wait that is
that just the study of it oh my god oh
my god
is that really good trying to get into
the medical man
trying to study this [ __ ] right chin do
you have flat feet yeah exactly i don't
mind mine
and i was on some cinderella [ __ ] and we
saw a glass slipper we put our foot in
there yeah we still got a lot of room
yeah
okay so i don't understand why he's
trying to we'll take it up we'll take
him out
once you came into air force
little shampoo
he said can't give me some lotion yeah
give me some lotion please
all right look we're gonna compare all
right go ahead
shout out shout out shout out
shout out to the dunks don't get that
sock off dog let's get the whole
the whole thing look at my foot you tell
me mom have an arch
compared to him compared to you i'm
[ __ ] cinderella dog oh [ __ ] he got a
massive arms you have no arch
you have the flattest foot i've ever
seen oh yeah also the bottom of your
feet are the widest
and they're also orange dude those are
flat you you have the hook
that's a bad foot let me just go just
because i am you don't have an arch
you're right all right you win i i
literally i was like look at that big
toe though
that big toe is thick that's the thick
ass big toe
look how flat your foot is don't you got
that weird foot thing
malik why are your toes so scrunched
together do they not breathe
yeah they are screaming shoes don't fit
my shoes just [ __ ] you
i was just feeding this [ __ ] it looks
like a foot binding you know what it is
like there's the ancient chinese that's
what's gonna say is there's like an
ancient chinese thing would it yeah
because back in
long time ago i don't remember exactly i
thought she was
like i'm there have you seen it you
never heard of a chin no you've never
heard of that wait what are you guys
talking about
like the chinese practice i've heard of
it yeah yeah where people like scratch
your foot yeah
and then they know like
everything's like compact in and it's
like [ __ ] up
because what small feet were like it was
a sign of beauty it's not a beauty i'm
with the child oh god i'm with the
chinese on that
oh man no but now
look at malik's feet
hold on let me get my phone out
[Applause]
oh my gosh hippopotamus feet man dude
bro that's
that's insane it
no that it looks like uh patrick from
spongebob
yes it does oh my god patrick oh cats
[ __ ] you mommy
what about the like the toe because the
toenails grow it's all a nightmare nah
and they put them in heels i'm also with
the chinese on that though i support
that
you wouldn't date a girl with a [ __ ]
size 14.
if she was super bad you would go
something she was super bad i would
we'd like trade shoes and [ __ ] that'd be
sick
this last 14. if she was better it's the
same chip yeah but she can't she can't
just be a regular girl
you gotta be ten yeah who would you
exception be like if this person or
harvey
laurie harvey so if lori harvey laura
harvey had a gigantic teen i would have
done that
here got it no harvey got it
who's who brian miles is that what's
that drake wrote a whole song about her
i'd have to say brian miles
bro there's a lot of instagram thoughts
that could have a size 15.
no no yeah we are yeah we wouldn't even
[ __ ] know
huh oh uh well no i'm not going to date
her
all right especially at a size 17. oh
hold on time that's all dude compared to
the world harvey or better than laura oh
come on that's that's a great that's an
old picture though
right well you go to instagram yeah
that's real brilliant
you know her i know he knows the
instagram handphone
off the top of the dome he knows exactly
what her screen she's been over there a
couple of times
right here look you you tell me you
wouldn't date that a size 16.
she ain't better than uh lori harvey man
she's beautiful but i i can't wait i
feel like she's not as pretty as that's
her there
yeah i don't even remember what laura
harvey looks like
she's beautiful though she's cool she is
cool she's hot okay
she's yeah she's super bad
that's her there's the horse all right
all right all right all right
size 14 size 14. she could have [ __ ]
up thank you
she could have a fin like a mermaid and
i would carry her from store to store
wet lassiana go pee from prowl family
look at that
god yeah she's called hey that's over
city stairs right is she
why didn't drake get her pregnant oh
because she turned down drinks
no she turned down drake he wrote a song
about oh
daddy that's called daddy's daddy wait
she turned down drake
wrote a whole song that is a chocolate
coin yeah drake takes l's
j drake takes it well was this drake
before this is way this is so far going
this ain't run through the six oh
this thing runs through she didn't see
that crib and turned him down no yeah
yeah exactly he didn't have the ovo
jordan's gonna turn it down oh okay dude
she's a bona fide
ted hold on chin go back uh-huh and go
go
go underneath that one you know this one
no that one's cool that's that one
is that her on the left or right bro
come on you know which one she is
one left got a forehead huh
i i i saw i got a predator vibe but you
so goddamn
he had to say that i know yeah she's
somebody always says
we just be sitting here all quiet and
[ __ ] she's so bad though
she makes money on instagram go up show
them this video real quick gonna
get off of it and we just we're gonna
leave it i'll go down go down i'm sorry
i'm only gonna shop at black owned
businesses
right now support what's her name real
madrid in support of bria
i'm only gonna shop at black gold there
you go
show a kkk member of this profile and
he's like ah they're not too bad
she's so bad i take the video down god
what video bro how old is she she's oh
right there in the middle chin
right there in the goddamn yup daddy was
she in a bathing suit i feel like we've
watched this before yeah we did it we
haven't seen this
i've never seen this one in my life so
understand look at all these chocolate
queens oh that one get out of here oh
okay we're just shut the [ __ ]
you could watch one brilliant miles just
yeah let's get these two out of here
yep okay nope don't want to see you guys
hold on here she goes
wait she's gonna give it to you wait a
minute she's gonna give it to you at the
end
that's her there yes you know that's her
oh she has flavor too
that's not nope that one needs to just
get to stop it
nope flat ass look at her look at her
look at her bro
nope no nope nope
some have little boots oh yeah she gave
it to her a little bit
she gave it to him style bender liked it
did he really
i like it i wasn't even paying attention
to the likes
he was like style better like that yeah
oh yeah
yeah okay we're good yeah yeah some
people are so beautiful man
god has his favorites he really does if
she has at the front
of the line when he's handing out beauty
oh my front of the line got everything
i was in the mid back let's be real
midway for what
the line of beauty i was like back in
the pack no
not me it depends what you're looking
for yeah okay depends on who you're
standing next to
yeah because la mid-back or like a
denver mid-back
oh denver i was front row
i'm a denver nine i'm an la-4
really i'm i was in an back of the line
i was in the back lying like it was a
krispy kreme you good everywhere no i'm
not
like man it's so i'm like a la you're
alex no
your hand six six you're saying la six
all right all right
there's there's some dudes walking the
street they're like god yeah
no with a haircut and you know hey okay
okay
seven is great i know but i gave you a
seven i know you gave me a second i gave
you six to start i'm sorry bro i
i roll around with this dude i see girls
just staring at me
i know what happened my mom does think
you're gorgeous too thank you
what about me nine brendan
what be honest what do you think about
that
you said [ __ ] i got it
i got it
[Applause]
the water
no
and daddy use a 10 bro that's hard to
find in l.a
you're irreplaceable chef
and it is true that is
can have you on the front cover no
yeah yeah he's [ __ ] stupid
when you when you blow up when you blow
up to patrice level or you can be
sponsored by gucci probably not
[ __ ] you you say your personality
i just
like he was terrified did you see uh
michael shanahan got his gap fixed yeah
you got his
[ __ ] up are you mad at him because i
was like dude that's your personality
like why would you
also you're 50. yeah why is it
he looks better with his like a great
grip does he look handsome
it looks kind of cr i mean no it's fake
teeth but again
i bet he goes but i feel like i like his
gap more it's more personality
i would be so mad at you if you got
yours fixed i can't give
up have you seen that girl
on uh on the smart perfect smile
commercials
she's like i used to be made fun of in
high school not anymore and she fixed
her gap oh really that damn you lost
character girl you got bullied into
fixing your teeth
so then so then that makes me a [ __ ]
dime my gap yeah you're a dime
hey you know it smells so funny
hey help me fight him dog
oh the brilliant i've seen some
instagram girls that are 10. there's
some girls at the zoo gym that are
straight up like nines
oh yeah it's true yeah bro drake turned
she turned down drake but again it
wasn't drake drake i would mess my
entire life up for her
my life being shamed i couldn't believe
you said she was okay with you i know
you know what
the first woo
come on we should have a conversation
now i agree though the more you look at
her the more you're like jesus christ
with the white pants i saw her in real
life with uh one more
she is thinking you know when you see a
girl i didn't scare me stick she see a
person
real skinny she was with dj clue she had
all these pants on oh she was dating dj
clue
she was just with him i don't know but
they pulled off in the piano i know my
replacement in my jeans will be the new
style oh
girl look at that girl in the background
just having to talk
look at him
exactly she she's slow winding and this
girl jumping i know
dude the party rock anthem is not
playing hopefully
i don't know guys oh my god look at her
though
oh okay all right all right chance
how's that only have 15 000 likes well
because this is uh
2016. she didn't blow up to like listen
you don't become a two eight
uh division champion by not shooting
shots that's true does she
i bet you uh follow him as well but
again you gotta be top
level hold on go back to that look at
this dork's comment
i'd rather be smoking with you i'd love
to have a woman like you with that ad
i think i wouldn't even think about
cheating anyone who cheats on women like
this is just a fool you can walk in that
all day i won't be tired of it
do you really think she's gonna comment
be underscore r underscore 15.
you just said shoot a shoe yeah that's
not really [ __ ]
that's nice that's him jacking off to
this picture and then writing a comment
afterwards yeah
god dawg look at that oh my god and she
hangs around nothing but
like dying pieces but again look at that
old man in the back behind him
that woman jack in it look at him i
wonder
uh in the back wait cat all right i'm
gonna
i wonder if she knows it's a white boy
summer oh i have an update on that later
um oh will you give me my number cheers
get it off
i've been trying to tell him he's
kissing me hey
gosh take it off
now what i'm saying cat because you're a
girl yeah i want you to give me my
number
are we talking la or general l.a and
then we'll go general
we'll go la then we'll go midwest yeah i
would say
let me sit up yeah
let me know when you're ready let me
know when you're ready yeah
smile now and remember you don't know
him okay i don't know him i don't know
him all right go ahead
chappella five wait wait wait wait wait
i'm gonna play you like that
together hey what's five plus five ten
asked to see if she's in the tariffs
she'll be like dog you a seven i'm like
yeah but my friend are three
so yeah i think in la if i'm going very
objectively i would say
malek's a six both of you are fives i
think regularly
you would be like an uh like normal
l.a in l.a i'm with cat on this in
l.a have you seen me with a haircut huh
yes i have you're a six
maybe a seven if you're but that's not
bad i feel like an la-6 is already
killing it if you're in l.a like five
and above you're fine
you have sex with your sock song all the
time
absolutely regular if i saw you on the
street like i was back home in san jose
i'd give you a seven
i'd give you a seven i'd give you even
maybe an eight
okay just like san jose like i would
walk around san jose
the tac nerd seven there's some fine
dudes in the bag i will say
they're
[Applause]
and now it's a
[Applause]
what do you give chin in l.a in l.a i'd
give chin
a such a dare
[Applause]
cheers he's gotten around i don't want
to play this game
no no dude we're spitballing ideas
[Laughter]
no one's ugly in here
how dare you your personality's
attention
that personality 10 though you keep that
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
we see all your vlogs channel i'm saying
if you don't know anybody
in here would you do a double the only
person don't take on this maybe me
because i'm so big
and then definitely malik he has a
handsome face okay i feel like
you're not double-teaming but here's the
thing chappelle
has like a very very like friendly
facial doesn't care anymore
someone help me fight
we know chappelle and he's attend to us
yeah his personality yo
you don't know him at all or chin and
you're just watching that stream
he goes yo what would you give those
guys
we almost need someone not in on the
show to rank yes yeah we need some
people to know yeah
you need objectively yo and awesome we
could have instagram do it but they our
fans kind of know us
yeah yeah you could be like hey what
would you give malik and now he just has
brian
miles you don't know if yeah we should
do like
our best we should go around uh malcolm
whenever they have new interns coming oh
yeah they're gonna actually have them
i'll just pull them out they kind of
work for me too so
brennan's a 10. yeah well i'm not a 10
year old i know i'm not true
i know i'm not 12. i can't he's 11. i
can call my friend that looked just like
brielle miles i had to step up that's
your friend
no she don't but again she doesn't know
you all though and she and i had to step
on the scale so she's super chill
chin oh you showing me her yeah her and
she's like up there with brienne miles
she can't judge us yeah you think what
she's out there with
brielle miles you think she
yes she is you think bro yes i think so
well let's have them
vote okay bring her up and you're right
you're right that was
unfair you guys are eights in san jose
now that i really think of it you're
right you're absolutely sure it came to
your senses
i've been to san jose are
yeah yeah uh hold on we just did it we
just yeah i know
i don't remember her name though i
couldn't even get a double take yeah you
couldn't get that's that's that was
double takes are hard it's hard to come
by a double take
i guess yeah how often do you double
take for people in normal life
i don't double take i just stay on it
you know immediately
okay i can call her right now if she oh
she's bad
that's that fake jet too i like that
[ __ ] that's that fake
i like that [ __ ] i like that [ __ ]
and she's a doctor she's a nurse yeah
she's a nurse so she's like take care of
people
and she's not she's not i'll take advice
i love you
so yeah what caught well she she's up
there
yeah she's up there yeah what's with the
the girl who i love 72 who's my soul
mate what's her name
bree breeze
dude i would let her give me the
vaccination she's so fine
damn what she don't even know okay all
right she's nursing training but all
right
um yeah but we can call her unbiased
ellie you just said
l.a why don't you just text her does she
like white boys like photos yeah
she bro take a picture of me right now
i'm sitting at your door okay she says
actually
she fails on tv
she's all a three she was like why are
you wasting my time i gotta study in
this video
who the [ __ ] is that all that dude
you sent me a highlighter
okay all right actually yeah i got to
find a picture yeah if i okay all right
we'll do that there how about we do that
because i have
right now i'm at the worst shape of my
life i want to go i want to go with my
pictures
i don't know what brandon says about it
but no so we should actually have
pictures that we like
and then put them up okay it can't be
from left more than a year ago
yeah no you can't you can be like yo
this like yeah yeah give us one from
cheerleading
we're all skinny well let's just take a
picture what are we doing
here's me in the ufc eight years ago
hey look it's so funny when a girl is
cutting you like let me get my best
picture forget
my right now buddy i'll send a
yeah daddy i lift yeah daddy started
working out
dude you know what a goal this is a goal
of mine
i want to be able to yeah yeah we're
about two years away from that
damn that's about two years yeah dude
those two
guys that we walked into oh yeah they
were [ __ ] remember i [ __ ] up their
video
yeah get out of the shot they had to
redo it
god damn it man i was like i'm so sorry
guys
i'm so sorry i just need a medicine ball
dude we're two years away from that
that's been good maybe
yeah maybe i'd say a year a year i want
to be able to take my shirt off
in zoo gold yeah i'll do that that'd be
good i only have to worry about my
lower half that'd be sick oh yeah now
you saw the quads
i took a picture of my question yeah he
took a bruh a little bit
do you mind i'll show i'll show you
[Music]
pictures i tell her like yo somebody
going
i go live i was impressed this one if i
got some uh
i had my shirt off i'm almost at 196.
but you always take your shirt off
that's true so you you got it i need to
get there you good
you know what i'm saying yeah bro i
believe me i don't you listen it's gonna
be like one year honestly i don't
believe it too because you're a hard
worker
yeah i mean i believe hard work bro i
mean dedication bro i'm your personal
chili hard work
once i learn how to flip bro i swear to
god as soon as you
can take your shirt off i hit a flip you
hit the foot yep straight up back flip
you straight for the back flip did you
send it to him
i said yeah it's coming you see what
this is looking like man oh
oh yeah break once okay okay
send it to your girl now
now you guys at the top we got to work
on that a little bit we got to work on
this
what what do you mean you want them to
have a teardrop i want to hit it exactly
it's a monsoon down there daddy that
[ __ ] is
a thick raindrop of muscle
i definitely couldn't send you a picture
like that right now all right
that's a swamp that's a kind of take
down the pants to anaconda dad
you've always had good legs not like
that
that's that's from all the [ __ ] we've
been doing with mark and i ride bikes
all the time but
i had sharks on yesterday a lot of
people said i was getting bigger haters
will say it's photoshopped
um that's it that's from jay's phone
that's a baby
that's a baby good phone yeah that's a
baby girlfriend
that's a good phone yeah you got them
legs if you're crashing them playing eat
them thighs dog
eat them you mean thai first daddy
i mean he usually says eat a mass first
so that's kind of better oh you usually
say that yeah he usually goes out
there's a lot of meat in the ass when
you say it like that yeah there's a lot
of meat in there
though everyone knows your glutes have
the most meat in them
get that ass jerky and get home fellas
that's your kid
go home guy happy hell no bro i'm good
on that
but yeah uh i feel i feel like i feel
bad for you chin you're not at la for
you
no you're not [ __ ] kidding me you
like appreciate that what are you doing
what do you think you are jen i'm not
going to tell myself
i want to know your thoughts i think
when i when i'm in like my best shape
when i'm
and i you know i do my hair i grow my
hair out 207
no i'll get myself i think i'm an lh 7
i'll give myself a 7.5 oh so you think
you hate
no no no no plus i'm super tall for an
asian yeah i think that'll help that's
true
that helps yeah we're adding all that
into it exotic
all that goes into this i know what do
you give jack
a scale la scale la scale la or miami
just just keep going we have such good
looking people
oh so wait wait we didn't have a miami
grade is it different from l.a
it's pretty similar because the women in
miami are
the body it's tough bodies miami like
their bodies are just
they don't they don't compare oh
[Music]
no but she said the whole package she
sent the whole but
this it starts here it starts with the
face too thin dog
yeah okay and we didn't put them there's
nothing wrong with your body however
looking at your feet
no you don't know you don't know you
don't know the whole package but
we can tell your feet are [ __ ] up from
a mile away are you serious no you can't
it's not not busting you you have a
great body you're sure suspect
your body's good everything about you up
into your foot
everything about you up until your foot
killing it
you're not looking at my feet if you're
a girl if you have sandals on wheels i
don't know i don't wear sandals i know i
respect yeah
those amount of gas cars i have some of
those with socks
exactly that's going to lower your score
what are you talking about if i ever
was on a beach i like how he wears those
shits on the flights too
disgusting
getting off the plane stepping up with
the [ __ ] custard
put one foot out all the way my heel
hanging off the bat
either way i'm just saying what would
you say you were wearing for la six
uh i think i think i'm gonna give myself
a seven for la
hell yeah i think l.a i get myself i
like your confidence
his personality you gotta factor all
that in no you gotta do this
just looks dude yeah personality he's a
10.
[Music]
but we know he's on la 10 right we know
he's not a 10
no i'm not i'm not a 10. nobody my
personality is great i'm not an lh
nobody said
you're l.a he's an la ten but he even
calls himself a 10. no he said a seven i
said seven i give him something la's
seven seven's high i give myself a six
so he's not so he came back he can't be
higher than you that's a c
that isn't no that's seven out of ten
that's a good score
that's a b x for l a yeah i think for
l.a it is okay then i'll give myself a b
and you give yourself a c yeah yeah can
you give yourself a while you give
yourself a six six no
i give myself the amount of bad [ __ ]
in l.a like
it's not necessarily like a diss to me
it's just like the the quality
of that is so crazy better than me
alec
[Laughter]
i mean just in this room
you're gonna think let's give it a
little time a little pause
i mean you got if you want to know
so who the [ __ ] a seven bro you what
you said in yourself out of us
out of like out of our friends yeah a
person that we know that's like
popping or whatever whatever i'd say i
say daley is a seven
seven he's bodybuilding you're better
looking than you think no
he has that long hair feels good looking
too man he was a good guy
he was a good [ __ ] you know what theo
and chris are seven
phones i'd say theo's a seven what are
you brian theo's a good looking guy
brian for 52 is nine yeah
you know what i'm saying
uh that's it that's all we know jake
what is jay
in l.a jay jay
you know what i'm going to stand up from
i love guys that's my guy
homie i'll give him a seven that's your
brother that's your brother
so you know
[Applause]
it's [ __ ] tough out of our friends
i'd say probably theo or chris
is the best looking out of the group
i'll put brian up there santino's a five
there's a red hair is what ginger is in
chrissy
this includes that's why that's why
that's why malik's so high
that's why your scoring is down
[Laughter]
daddy come on daddy
this
stevie's like you got that face and big
dick because just being that small
being that small you seen his little
foot you steve you know i love you
you've seen that little foot
to be fair i tell him that all the time
i said if he was six feet he'd never
look in my direction
no he's still would cat no stevie yeah
let's be real with that
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
out of our crew stevie's the best
looking okay
italic okay like they're they're like we
have a great time we have a get out you
and
texas is a lot of southern hospitality
down there so it's like yo
personality personality you got affected
texas likes big dudes though so there's
that
yeah we're bigger dude yeah so y'all are
dying pizzas in texas
we're sevens in texas yeah i guess yeah
okay you see some dimes with some big
burly
yeah yeah
uh yeah stevie and then what's mark
because mark's gonna be in austin
oh yeah that's a beautiful [ __ ]
um i'd say mark's
he's body dominant yeah he has that long
hair but he's that's
he's got the height but you got to like
hit that flavor what do you mean
you don't like this if you don't like
that flavor like i'll show some girls
him like oh my god he's hideous
you show something like oh my god he's
gorgeous
he looks like uh the witcher on netflix
that guy with the silver hair
built up he it was the actor who played
superman henry cavill i believe oh yeah
ritzy oh i love superman
just wait for it that's the type of look
that mark has
long gray hair looks like he could be on
game of thrones or some [ __ ] yeah no
yeah all right
but hold on is that mark though
that's that's if you're telling me mark
can't be his stun double you're [ __ ]
out that's mark right there that's mark
that is mark yeah that's just so okay
marcus
depending what you're into because
either eight or two and you're eight
you ate all around yeah whatever
thank you but i'm not in it i'm not i
want to be with the guys that's how much
i want to be a seven
you want to be a seven put on a little
weight i am i'm gaining
pulling away don't drop yourself to a
seven what do you mean if you put some
weight a bit seven
if i put on weight yeah but like i'm
trying to give you like i'm gonna get oh
no i don't know
you don't [ __ ] i'm gonna get to a
dime you'll be a 10 though you're
probably gonna be able to muscle
what would justin be if he got like
shredded which i was trying to encourage
him to do
if he if with that face if he got rid of
him not like dude
oh [ __ ] you talking about my oh [ __ ] no
i thought it wasn't no no that's the
elephant in the room
i said what's justin you all took it
upon yourself but you know
you know you [ __ ] up right now you
know what you were doing
you know justin's not here too
brittany that man is beaut like he's
like mark dude he's different and like
it's a different vibe you got to be into
it like mark you got to be into that
look
and you shred it though you know justin
got a lot of tattoos
yeah he does yeah yeah his fashion is
great
dress is great shoe plugs yeah
funny money i've no yeah but again
all great assets that's all personality
though we talk about look yeah
look physical looks like i could say i
said
physical like that that's on you like
actually your stature looks like you got
like here's that
thin frame yeah he always have a fresh
haircut or
by the way we saw him in san marcos he
had a little shave spot
this [ __ ] up himself i said god damn
your hair's [ __ ]
oh
but jim you don't really know justin
what would you give them there you go
i would i wouldn't give a thumbs up yeah
yeah
it's a little aggressive yeah i'll get
i'll see most everyone's five
thank you talking
i feel like he's got swagger too so that
yeah i feel like that has to count right
that factors out but it doesn't he's not
tall he said
what is the whole package then thank you
you are you moving the goal
[ __ ] head to toe just physical looks
no swag shot and you put it on a wall
like we're casting agents we don't we
just going like this
are we all in speedos or something like
that so no you just dress regular just
regular everyday clothes okay and you
you look at justin what would you give
them you're the casting director
you're four or five
chappelle chapelle i'm looking at you
man be real
my math is this is like american idol
okay what would you give him dawg yeah
come on dawg randy randy chappelle would
i give him justin yeah
does he listen to the pod no no he's not
you won't hear this
i feel like someone's going to send it
to him i don't right
your friend's talking about you yeah
okay he don't care what do i give justin
yeah wait cutter justin
without the without the swag like yeah
without the swag like
you like let's say you had a sister and
she was like man i want you to hook me
up with somebody
i'm sure let me see the friends you go
on the road with and then you showed her
justin
i'd take her right to malik first of all
no no it's not about me right now
it's about justice so when i take her to
justice yeah you're like
she was like oh what do you give him
it's tough to be real no it's all right
it's the true first right the truth
hurts
go ahead you get myself go ahead what'd
you give him i gave him a seven
you're full of [ __ ] i'm not your boy
seven because
you know justin you know if i said six
six
you give him a six i give him a six you
i give him a three
you know i give him a three and there's
nothing wrong with that
i appreciate you being honest though
yeah the way this game works what'd you
give jessica
at the same time killing he killed it as
a three
what'd you get you gave me
that's right and i like the truth that's
[ __ ] up but let's get the cat would
you trust cat's opinion
i'd say i'd give him you would give him
no three i'd give him a four
honestly i'd give him a four no he's got
to be a five
man he kills it he kills you here's the
thing i think it's impressive that
him he's gay with us giving him all
these like lower scores
he still pulls girls left and right
pulls him left
yeah he has no issues pulls more hoes
than anybody in my mind it's more
impressive
yes it's much more impressive so you
said like okay if you saw me like uh
right you meet him and you're like oh
absolutely yeah he is gay yeah
justin's funny he's funny he's a great
person yeah
it's okay all right 10 game with or
yeah what do you mean i mean i'm i'm
gonna be straight up honestly because
you don't know
please yeah okay wait did she already
give them before
yeah i would say isn't it tough to do
just do it i wanna go five but let me
i'm gonna go four point five
that matters right now it's between four
point five that's good four four point
five is good all right that's what
that's fair i'll give him a four yeah
malik i already said five oh you said
seven
first which is just unrealistic yeah and
you're awesome
but his face no i i didn't mean that no
because
he said what's justin said that face
yeah you didn't say that
well we didn't even say it you said that
face you that's my guy
hello can we cut that um i'm saying this
listen because justin be mad at me
should be more mad at you
because i said nothing about this thing
well let's be honest with the glasses it
doesn't fit
his face i tell him that straight i'm
like bro take the glasses off
right and when it's with the glasses off
he has like a unique look about it
super unique
watch justin not be on the next broad
day yeah he's like man [ __ ] y'all [ __ ]
yo
three three
and i give myself a 5. that's fair
that's fair that's fair all right you
don't think we sixes no
all right i've seen sixes all right all
right what do you got for carnival
all right okay so there was
a uh article released recently saying
that emma watson stormed
off of the set of seth rogen's film uh
what was it called uh this this is the
end this is it
uh for that scene where have you guys
have you guys seen the film that we're
like like the first thing that happens
is the it's like the end of the world
all these celebrities are in it all
these comedians
so emma watson had a pretty big role in
the film
and what ended up happening was there
was a scene that ultimately ended up
getting changed and it was the scene at
the end
where channing tatum is in like this
leash and harness and like the sex mask
and his like asses out he's like danny
mcbride's pet basically
yeah yeah yeah it's great uh emma watson
was supposed to be in it but then uh
as they were changing what that scene
was gonna become she said she wasn't
comfortable with it and walked off set
and headlines made it seem like she was
being a diva and so
seth rogen actually came out and said
that it wasn't her fault they talked
about it and it just wasn't something
that she was comfortable with because
they changed the scene but they were
cool afterwards like yeah
she was leaving she was like i don't
want to do that yeah and then she helped
come back and promote the movie and
everything
but paparazzi and the media made it seem
like she was being a diva
so why is it so quick to call someone
meanwhile these [ __ ] weren't
even on the set or know anything
yeah and it's years after this movie was
made or released too
yeah i was like didn't this one come out
a long time ago yeah a long time ago
yeah that's a great movie yeah kevin
hart in there right now
oh it's such a good movie kevin hart's
not in there it's a great movie
the scene
afterwards yeah she dies yeah uh but
what happens was when they were filming
the scene uh michael sarah's like oh no
you can slap me as hard as you can
rihanna's like are you sure
he's like yeah so the slap in the movie
is a real slash
and he she she slapped him so hard that
afterwards he couldn't record anymore
and he's just laying down on the set
damn really [ __ ] up he's like wiped
out harder than a little boosie slap
i don't know if it's not hard enough no
not that hard but
because he gets all he's on drugs and he
starts hitting on her
she slaps the [ __ ] at him what about boy
michael sarah
anyway still being super bad oh yeah he
grabs her ass because all yeah he's on
drugs
he's like trying to get [ __ ] up how's
it going you know uh jay yeah i don't
think i've ever actually met you
the mindy kids million dollar baby thank
you so much for saying that
oh my god if i don't [ __ ] with michael
sarah tonight i'm going to vote
look he's doing all this coke
psychiatrist um
that's not cool that's my michael last
night
[ __ ] up jason we're playing a game man
say cheese baby nice cheeks baby
nice cheese baby he had to lay down and
i said nice cheeks baby
that was the uh the part that they wrote
now he really slapped her
uh no like he slapped her ass like kind
of lightly
[ __ ] out of him because he was like oh
that's a great job rihanna's a 10. i was
about to say yes brian is ten yeah
i would ask him does anyone else ooh sex
like rihanna
no not like rihanna rihanna is different
she's just such a bad
baddie in bed i've been mm-hmm she's
that person whereas like
i would let her [ __ ] my man and it's
perfectly fine i encourage that's yours
yes that's mine rihanna yeah
there you go oh that's a good i would
want to [ __ ] anyone who's six
more like rihanna maybe maybe cardi or
meg the stallion
yeah but they're not on that like
there's something different about
rihanna i don't know what it is
like just a little bit like you see her
and she's always talking about her ass
and stuff
and she can twerk some of the beasts and
cardi you could put cardinals
she talked about drugging dudes and
stealing from them she's talking about
how to get my teeth fixed because
i no she said she was worried getting
her teeth fixed she thought it'd [ __ ] up
her head game oh my god that turned
out that's sex right there yo yeah but
you know can compete with rihanna no
rihanna you see right
ooh dog makes my dick jump
at six get the jumping okay oh yeah
so uh this video is going viral i
believe this was
recorded at the end of 2020 it's an
elevator footage
from sweetie's old apartment building
that she used to live at
in north hollywood um this clip is
basically
it seems like they gotten some sort of
altercation the video starts where
sweetie is like she swings on cuevo and
misses she runs back
to get this like orange suitcase or
something tries to run
out of the elevator cueva then grabs her
pulls her back in
and they both fall and people are
speculating that
this was a abusive relationship and
that's why they ended up breaking the or
super besides
it's his video game his video stuff oh
she tried to hit him he moved yeah
and then he's like man come on here i'll
give my game man oh wow they are not
doing well
no ah that's not i wouldn't say that
yeah i want to say yeah i'd say it's a
toxic relationship but yeah 100
i don't think it's not like he's abused
because if he if he wanted to he could
have done more
well again she's at
and when she walks out of the elevator
at the end of this clip she's kind of
limping out oh that's nice
as of now i don't think either of them
have addressed this particular video
because it
was already it's an older video yeah
they were still together during
this time it was the end of 2020. and i
don't think either of them have ever
talked about being in like a physical
she's a bad altercation
with each other it's just like they said
it was cheating so i don't really know
what to make of it with this
relationship also he was on the fire
because migos got into a fight
uh yesterday oh really just in l.a boy
just because oh the guy who runs that
meme page right yeah he was
they beat him up and jay and i was
talking he jumped them right i like how
down they are with each other
you never see them when they're about to
jump in joe buddy
they're like what you're gonna do dude
that was at the uh i was the i was
no i don't know was it the grammys it
was the grammys because i was also
working oh yeah
i remember was a big deal yeah and that
was like the complex yeah
yeah i was like yeah and he goes like
well damn what you're going to do then
man they're all
right all three of them like put their
because he was like he was like this
interview over he was like well [ __ ] cut
it off
he didn't want nothing yeah yeah
all of them got up all of them i love
how down they are for it so it's two
brothers and a cousin yeah and they're
like
if you [ __ ] with one you [ __ ] with all
three is there uh
is there a video no there's no video now
jay and i was ranking
who has the best hands now he said
offset and i say
take off because his name take off yeah
great name okay
and then we go quaver we know that dates
cardi b right yep so we can he she
he street dude we hear he swings first
that's what i'm saying yeah he's pretty
street
joe budding crazy though what yeah joe
budden's big
he's skimming he's kind of smaller joe
budden's not small
looks like he's stacked offset is six
one i didn't know that
really i think it's called what it looks
like oh he's only six i thought
it was like six four and he's but he
also looks jacked
joel button yeah i don't see him he's
like skinny fat you ski
you tripping bro oh apparently his
podcast they broke up the two the two
co-hosts on the show
that was a good podcast i love that puck
yeah they're great
but i guess the other two there was like
some real issues as far as paying [ __ ]
and then
they decided they did they like they
boycotted the show and they just didn't
show up
mm-hmm hey so you ever seen a video
where uh joe budden
a fan throws a uh a brick at joe button
and he's chasing him
oh yeah he was a kid oh yeah yeah
yeah he was home i hope they figured out
listen man
podcast especially when there's fame and
money involved it gets dicey come on
your boy knows it firsthand people get
famous and people change
so i'm i'm i'm i wonder what really
happened with that well maul did they
feel like they were more
to the story or they felt like they
needed more i don't i don't know what
happened
we could talk to maul you know mom was
on that podcast uh maul the male
male he's his guy
the black guy the black guy yeah yeah
yeah there's the white guy and the black
guy the black guy yeah that's what i'm
saying
you know ball wanted to fight him
exactly he kept fighting and then he
thought didn't think he was serious then
he was like oh you're serious yeah
we gotta we gotta take a break man bro
like we shouldn't be fighting each other
can we have them all
yeah yeah yeah yeah sometimes he's not
my favorite on there you're not he's not
uh it's tough because
i like their dynamic uh yeah and yeah
that it's the chemistry that that's what
i'm saying
yeah like like it's gonna be tough for
joe budden just to
carry on with two other dudes mm-hmm
chemistry is what makes wait both of the
dudes wanted to leave
they're but they both left they wasn't
getting paid they're not on there oh is
that weird
see joe but joe says it's not a payment
thing but again that what you're going
to have to do you've got a
he was basically saying that's complete
[ __ ] it's all about money
well he was he said like basically it's
so much factored in like yo
uh he didn't really go into debt but he
was like yo that's not the issue
it's more money yeah of course his money
that's what like
under the tweets underneath again that's
twitter but joe button making money
bank too and he just signed that deal uh
and they know exactly how much he's
making they're probably like hold up so
you
you put come on two plus two is four
yeah
all right good mouth doug no problem
what else you got i
really like to know this is a quick one
for you brendan um
and morty is gonna come back for their
new season and it's gonna be releasing
on
june 20th [ __ ] yeah my tigers you and
tiger are
just gonna watch this well a bummer is
uh you know they try canceling them
really try canceling so they like what
was the reason for it
something stupid was it like a joke yeah
some yeah something stupid
let me see the trailer though favorite
cartoon of all time
never seen it it's too quiet yeah
chapelle you should watch this tonight
with your girl watch uh pickle rick
what's that it's one of the episodes
favorite cartoon about time it's so well
done and so it's really creative too
it's so cool it's the most creative
cartoon you've ever seen
there's one scene where they invade well
uh
they like get out because the spaceship
stopped working so and
rick tells morty like dude stay in the
[ __ ] spaceship
he gets out to help him he gets bit by a
snake and so then they go to
the snakes from a world of all snakes
the entire episode is snakes going
and then there's subtitles of the snakes
talking really it's so interesting
it's so funny if i don't like it we
fighting i'm telling you it's terrible
if you if do you like cartoons though
you got you like american dad
that type of like raunchy cartoon
american dad south park
adults i used to watch did you watch uh
big mouth
i only watched it when we were in uh i
love big mouth that was i fell off of it
but yeah i was cracking up with that
rick and morty so well done okay all
right
yeah i never watched i never watched
cartoons growing up not that i realized
oh man that sucks
that's sad is that sad yes yeah is it
your background
stimpy rugrats gummy bears bouncing here
and there everywhere damn this is the
afternoon
what about duck tales yep tail spin keep
going
none of that dragon ball z dark wing
duck segments not dragon ball z
dark wing duck vegeta tgi of
cool step by step restaurants i watch
that [ __ ]
you watch step by step full house family
math i'm trying to think what was my own
favorite show you know children
i used to like a little house on the
prairie a lot
i just like that right i just watched
bonanza you you oh
so that yeah that block you would do
those you're [ __ ] dope yeah you're a
fool uh
mama's family i love mama's family i'm a
family four yeah
you never [ __ ] with the ducktales or
darkwing duck
chipping down
i don't even actually i actually don't
even remember what duck tales is
this is the three nephews of scrooge
mcduck live with screwdriver
those kids yeah i don't know
no yeah i've never seen i can't never
play the video game on nintendo i know i
know what it is but i don't think they
have that
i know what these things are but i
couldn't tell you anything about them
you know i got sued by disney for what i
made uh scrooge mcduck
uh him jumping in fire in the kid's
shirt
one thing you don't want to do was [ __ ]
with disney
cause it was like it was like a play on
words and i thought i could use it and
get away
really oh dude what if i posted the
shirt it sold out in like minutes
but disney ate my lunch
they don't [ __ ] around it's disney what
about when people used to make those
shirts with all the [ __ ] uh like a
bugs bunny but he was dressed all
looney tunes and then they're like uh
yeah
no there were thugs but they were uh
there what was that what uh
you don't talk about though right uh
yeah with the two guys that were closed
backwards the two
crews crossed chris they were crisscross
yeah they had the clothes on backwards
and then
on the back it was them too same thing
that's what i'm saying what
yeah they do they were one of those
tunes though there were warner brothers
disney disney got that [ __ ] on because
disney
wants to be seen in a very specific way
they don't that's why they're
suing uh the company that made uh little
nasdaq shoes
they're suing them nike suit them like
oh no like those big companies don't get
it yeah remember that t-shirts was like
yo you see the police
warner brother yeah yeah yeah those were
great i would get those there's a little
circuit and the flavor yup i remember my
dad bought a fubu shirt and i was like
you can't wear this
he had a red foo boo shirt i was like
you can't wear it
you know i'm on comedy central this
whole week for the 100 best roast
moments
and nicki glaser's the host my dad's
like that nicki glazer what a gorgeous
woman
you ever talk to her like yeah she's
cool with that he's like nice person
like why
are you asking
so your dad likes nikki glaze or your
mom likes malik yeah okay
my mom also likes brian that's cool who
likes who likes me
so this is blake griffin uh
i like you chicago
i'm sorry you were so nice earlier i
wait what are you saying yeah what did
you really bother i'm counting man
there's something going on in the back
you know because she's single
you know it's like griffin he's gorgeous
maybe he's like you wanna grab drinks
after she's like that sounds so fun oh
my god yes
and he's like yeah man this would be fun
and then they go out there and do
this yeah
nikki look at you
you damaged little climber
way to roast the chick who openly is
crushing james davis
and crush her spirit blake blake
griffith is cool as [ __ ]
i met him nice guy i met him in montreal
in jfl
he was like yo i [ __ ] with your comedy
super nice guy really
yeah nice he was nice yeah got a dope
picture together too
one of my favorites
oh you want you want to see a dead body
um
we might have no rock before coming on
friday should we do this right yeah do
it yeah hold on let me tell you okay
so this was posted on bar stool um to my
understanding you probably know a lot
more about this than i do
but michael rappaport was hired to do
some work with bar stool a few years ago
and that relationship ended pretty badly
and after he got fired from bar stool i
guess he
made some sort of shirt of like him
[ __ ] dave portnoy
and then dave portnoy then released a
shirt
from bar stool saying that like he had
herpes or something and there was a
lawsuit then filed
so what happened is uh rap from my
understand obviously rapport is a close
friend
so from my understanding rapport was
working with barstool
he started making fun of some of the
employees and some of their shows on
twitter
you know rapport's rapport and then
portnoy got mad
and then released him like was like oh
we can't have this
fired him and then made shirts of him as
a clown with herpes
so then rapport uh opened you know a
lawsuit against him it's definition of
character
and so now there's all this beef and
then i yeah bar
barstool posted this yeah and yesterday
i believe it was barstool and dave
portnoy released a clip
from the deposition that dave portnoy
had with uh michael rapport's lawyer
yeah tossed out in court
yeah his case got tossed out and i guess
uh kevin durant was talking [ __ ] to
michael rappaport as well through dms i
guess they go back and forth a lot
and michael rappaport took a bunch of
screenshots posted it
online and people are making fun of
michael rapport now saying
why would you post a bunch of dms where
kevin durant is bodying you
in your instagram though right uh
i don't know i don't know as of now but
kevin durant's making fun of him saying
how are you gonna let dave portnoy uh
make fun of you and then you're gonna
call your lawyer this and that
he's trying to fight michael rappaport
as well 10 a.m that's a weird time to
fight though someone attended
it's just an early fight but uh kevin
durant is going to win the championship
i i i feel like but it was what
i was talking with jay jay was like what
did you want kevin durant to do
like so the tweet was the greats are
sensitive
they care about what the public thinks
of them my thing with kd though dude you
have
whatever 400 million dollars a bank he's
my favorite player but dude why are you
[ __ ] on michael report
but also it comes with territory rapport
talks
i wouldn't even make it worth my [ __ ]
time no but he talks so much [ __ ] like
kd
and kd is online yeah kd knows that
online so his burner account burner
accounts imagine
the dm skip bayless get but i'm saying
that he was mad that kevin durant didn't
do the
interview on nba tnt with shaq and chuck
and all them
and he was like i did do it but he was
just like responding like yes and no
and then he was like yeah his feelings
and he tweeted that and katie was like
man you're a [ __ ]
and that's how it started oh that's all
right yeah like he was just tweeting so
we get rapport in here we'll see what
what he says
yeah all right he called me so we'll see
he said call me back so we'll see okay
all right i want to know well
lebron hate got to stop hates on lebron
who's he like that's what i'm saying
will you either lebron or kd those are
the two best thank you guess giannis
what you know what i'm saying as far as
like big big dogs
if you don't like but who do you [ __ ]
with then rap that's my thing like
so who do you like yeah yeah literally i
would love a little
beast that's your little monster he's on
all the smoke uh i know next week next
week oh [ __ ]
yeah he'll be in here what does she got
jen
this is an update to white boy summer
yeah man you can't hear it i know
it's like i'm a fan i love this guy
yo bro that's a sick shirt black queen
got the black queen shirts
and uh what i really want to see is i
want to see some
white boys and some black queens wearing
each other's shirt me with a knife
this this just attacked me with the
knife no i didn't
did i take it this [ __ ] just attacked
me with a knife
did i put did i attack through or
[Music]
wow
she just attacked me with a knife you
better get out my face
she just attacked me with a knife
there's the proof she's mad because i
caught her stealing
or maybe it's not stealing my money
taking my credit cards and charging
her yo bro is that someone she's he's
dating or something wait what
i do not know i saw this this morning
and i was like ooh
that was a weird video jimmy's checking
in with the streets my boy summer is not
going well so far it might have to be a
boy someone instead it's well we know
it's a thick boy summer so that's his ex
oh his eggs oh okay
i'm glad everybody's up in arms because
i said white boy summer
yeah i don't get it either i don't know
obviously you know
jordan posted it was like yeah it's a
black dude summer i don't give a [ __ ]
why does everybody care he's a white boy
he's saying that yeah
would you rather say what i'm saying
yeah what's he supposed to say
i know that name kiana parker so it's
real then yeah she's uh that's not good
deanna parker kiana parker yeah so i
took back
that took place in january eight oh
that's all i guess the video just came
out then oh god
oh oh should be like yeah white boy
silver in my ass oh there's just
still a white boy somewhere it's still
white boys
stay strong doug we should get him on
the show
oh that'd be great
all right this is a little bit of a
downer but it's also good so you know
about that attack on the asian
woman just yesterday joe coy posted
about it the guy that looked like yo j
simpson yeah the crazy dude so he
actually a little background on him he's
caught now
and uh he killed his mother about two
decades ago
he's on parole and he's yeah lifetime
parole but then now of course he's back
in jail
uh he did do some sort of like hate
stuff yeah he said like you don't belong
here to the woman
she was walking to church jesus and then
he just randomly attacked her and the
people around him
in the building he didn't do anything
they didn't do that's the bomber that's
yeah
it's so crazy here's the other thing
people like well he's mentally ill no
he's a piece of
[ __ ] man we gotta quit chalking up to
everything he's mentally ill he's just a
bad dude man
yeah terrible person off the streets he
killed his own mother [ __ ]
oh mentally ill man that guy just we
need to get him the right help now you
need to [ __ ] lock
him in a [ __ ] steel cage or put him
down yeah
all right he can beat up a [ __ ] poor
elderly lady piece of [ __ ]
yeah that was a terrible attack mental
illness we just need him with the right
help no you don't
lock him in there let the homies run a
train on them
and this article is from uh peter rig
editor
this i have so many thoughts about this
too so this is a trans woman
she's a model and activist and then she
was yeah
and then she posted a tick tock saying
that uh tsa is transphobic i'll just
play it for you first
because what t-a-t-s-a stopped her yeah
i'll yeah so let me play real quick
hold on a sec let me refresh
can we talk about how horrible it is to
travel while being transgender
sometimes i always have immense anxiety
leading up to going through
security and this means that i totally
recognize the privilege of having all of
my documents correct
so the gender marker on my license for
example says female but going through
the scanner there's a male scanner and a
female scanner
in the tsa checkpoint and looking at me
you know i look like a woman and i am a
woman so that's great
i love having such assuming privilege
when i feel unsafe such as in an airport
but going through the scanner i always
have an anomaly between my legs that
sets off the alarm
and so she asked me if i had anything in
my pants and i told her no and she's
like well maybe it's just like the metal
on your shirt so let's scan you again so
i did and then it set it off again and i
was like look i'm trans just pat me down
and her solution was do you want to be
scanned as a man instead
i didn't but i ended up doing it and
then my boobs set off the scanner
because of course so i try to make a
joke of it i was like oh yeah there's a
lot of plastic in there it's fine
so then she was like okay well we have
to pat you down and she was like do you
want a man to do it i said no
absolutely not so she's upset
they're just trying to figure out what
to do right when they see it and
obviously she's a
a pretty human being they're like why is
there this big [ __ ] stick between her
legs so they're trying to find drugs and
you know illegal [ __ ] so i don't think
tsa is transphobic
i think they're yeah they're just trying
to do their job like this is weird
usually when a girl comes through here
we don't see
yeah big ass dick well listen to it i
was waiting for it i was like okay
okay okay yeah i know and then i thought
yeah that's not it
and then tsa being like god do you want
a man or a guy like they're just
yeah they're trying to be accommodating
exactly they're trying especially
thinking about that tsa
has no experience with trans people so
they're like do you want man or like how
do you do this you're just trying to
figure out
this is the problem man like let them
figure it out like they're like
do you want a man or a woman like how
dare you like i don't [ __ ] know dude
like we've never had this this is a rare
occasion for us
we're not trying to be disrespectful
yeah no i don't think someone checked
that hog in your pants
check that hole it's like you're
smuggling drugs down there daddy
um probably pack it too probably yeah i
feel like you alerted the [ __ ] sister
yeah a female scanner then a male
scanner so of course oh something's
going to pop off
i should say can they not ask questions
because then because then the cartel is
going to go oh
we can just disguise women as trans and
get any drug we want through because it
because america's so woke they're not
gonna do [ __ ] they're so scared damn
that's how it works
a lot of miss delphi is at the airport
yeah okay
i would say joanna man i love that movie
who is [ __ ] the worst she was
knocking on me
queen james okay this is luke bryan
country stinger yeah he's great uh he
got he went fishing and
got this trouble hook stuck into his
finger i'll show you hold on it's tough
to get out though because the hooks but
check it out it's in there too
oh that's bad this is going to leave a
mark
for sure that's in my bone well
russ my guitar tech i invited russ on a
fishing trip
and leave it to me so i ruined the
fishing trip
but we'll be back on the water in about
25 minutes
[Music]
how do you get it stuck like that i
don't know oh it happens all the time
like even if you got stuck somewhere
like pulling them out yeah like even if
you get stuck on a tree and you try to
pull it back
it'll launch back at you okay yeah how
do you take it out
it's do you just like like cut off the
uh hook part the little arrow if it goes
all the way through you can do that you
cut it off
but usually you take a string you take a
string if it's in your
hand you take a string tied against the
hook and then you push
the hook down so that the barb is like
it's not just rubbing as much yeah
i'd rather just cut this that's why i
went to the hospital the hospital do it
for you no problem
have you had that problem i've hooked
myself many times yeah
i like one i like a song by luke bryan
which one i like that uh
rain is a good thing yeah that's a good
that's a fun song
he's got a lot of fun songs yeah he's
great on american idol
very nice guy so this is britney spears
talking about the documentary about her
and then why this is a little weird is
because she's dancing
while she's saying how much the
documentary hurt her
first you can read whatever she wrote
here i didn't watch the documentary but
for what i
did see of it i was embarrassed by the
light they put me and i cried for two
weeks as well
i still cry sometimes i do want i do
what i can in my own
spirit spirituality with my with myself
to try and keep my own joy love
happiness
everyday dancing brings me joy i'm not
here to be perfect perfect is boring i'm
here to pass kindness
so she posted that but then she just has
this going on
i can't play the music but so she just
posted that and then started dancing
like this
she's a little crazy man i brought a i
bought a
free britney t-shirt did you i feel like
the hype's over
that [ __ ] didn't fit though oh dude it
was it was during the hype
yeah i tried that [ __ ] i was like damn
i should say free breath
[Laughter]
[ __ ] says ree whitney
[Laughter]
what is that oh my god i was already
wearing the [ __ ] that's
a joke you told my girls put that [ __ ]
on [ __ ]
your girl wearing it now yeah i gave it
to her because i was like
i can't fit this [ __ ] is that it it was
xo uh one more
we all saw this i think what this crazy
rap thing have you seen this
is this this is insane look at looks
like a homeless guy that taught rats how
to do tricks
bro look how you keep coming back is
there music in there
okay i can't do that watch watch the
first one don't tell that with this day
don't go how crazy is this [ __ ] he's
just those are his homies he's training
that's the craziest part damn that's
cool that's hard you know how many
diseases
they found like the bubonic plague on
rats dude
what yeah they have all sorts of [ __ ]
i i still don't get it i've never been
like i can't even get close to a rat
they're cool looking though they're
badass
damn that's pretty dope that is crazy
yeah a little too friendly with them
rats
uh we're in austin texas oh no in
naples florida april 15th through 17th
is naples florida
then austin texas vulcan gas company
theater
april 22nd through the 24th get tickets
at f-a-t-k-z
dot-com but baby all right man we some
fives we out
we shout out to the survived
the hundreds and sopatura for this
collab it's pretty sick that's shirt
shout out to my boy derek green for you
know hooking this up
and then shout out to these uh you know
these cool gray fours you know
shouts out everywhere shouts out to me
being at la 7.
i thought we were five no we are not
fives i will not we are kings
and we are sally
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
quick to flip on the tip change the
script twosome to do some austin
coming up naples florida first april
15th 17th
austin april 22nd 24th gas vulcan
company
i'll bring these there for you austin oh
supreme one
mm-hmm yeah big brother
big brother okay cat cat that's some fly
ass shoes on right now okay
okay
yep
here